それで新しい概念を考えたんです
進化の衝動と発展の衝動
私は進化と発展というのは 2つに分けたんです
これはちょっと英語だったらちょっとやりにくいんです
で それほどまあイボリューションと言いますからね
進化にはね 発展といえばプログレスなんですけど
やっぱりプログレスという場合はイボリューションも入っちゃうんですね
デベロップメントプログレスという
その単語をどちら考えたっても
イボリューションということも入っちゃうんです
だから日本語はそれがないんだから
まあ便利なもので この場合はね
便利でない時もあります
進化の衝動っていうのは
努力 励むこと 精進なんです
あの猿の進化で考えてください
どうって難しいことじゃないんです
もと猿でした生き物が今人間やってますからね
それは何十万 何万年経ったっけ
わからない私は ホーモ・エレクトスから普通のホーモ・サピエンスまではね
20万年はかかったんでしょうね
もっとかな まあ私は現代知識はございませんので
皆様そこら辺研究なさって調べてください
で 一番古い猿がね 人間に変わってきたところから
また まあそれは学校の教科書にもありますからね
すごい長い時間を経て我々は進化してきたんです
その進化をなぜできたかというと
いつでもチャレンジしていたんです
精進していたんです 一息しようかとかね
お腹いっぱい食って木の下で寝ようではないかという生活ではなかったんです
常に無理にチャレンジして進化していったんです
それはそんなに疑問あるならば
後で言ってもそれは違いますという考え方あるならば
無理にチャレンジすることで進化していたんです
それで だからこの努力ということは衝動なんです
努力しましょうと そうすると進化するんだよと
2番目 発展の衝動って何なのかというと
怠けることなんです これがちょっと理解しにくいでしょうね
怠けるとどうやって発見発展するのかと
でも文明っていうのは怠けという土台の上で成り立っているんです
怠けるといろんなものが発展する
洗濯なんかはやりたくないとか怠けたでしょうに
それで男たちにブーブーと文句言ってたでしょ
で 男たちはもううるさいんだから
では洗濯機を開発しようと
それでうちの家内も怠けられるでしょうと
だから発展はそれだけなんですよ
飛行機であろうか 船であろうが
もう電車であろうが もう何から何まで乗り物
文化はすごいことでしょう
あらゆる機械 あらゆる道具
もう何でも 怠けるためにできているんです
例えばもう寒さっていうのはどうったことないんですよ
でももう寒いは寒いのは嫌やとかね
暖かいところで怠けたいんですね
それであらゆるまた技術を発展する
結果として もう 1年中暑いところで生まれた私は
まだまだ体が大丈夫なんですけど
もう寒い国で生まれた日本の方々は
私ほどは寒さにはもう対応できない
体がむちゃ壊れている
だからこれすごく面白い現象なんですよ
なんでコンピューターがあるのかというと
明らかに怠けるためなんです
なんであらゆる機械あるのかというと
昔もトンネルを掘りたかったら
みんな手で掘って掘って
今はそうじゃなくて 機械持ってたらサーッと掘って
そのままコンクリートで固めて終わりということ
だからそういう機械も怠けるために
てるんです だから文明は発展の衝動が怠けであって
進化の衝動は努力であるとわかってほしいんです
で 今の人間は発展するために努力しているでしょ
そうすると何が増えるんですかね
どんどん怠けになるんです
しかし 誰一人も怠けって素晴らしいものだと言わないんですよ
だからもうインチキ詐欺もいいところなんです
偽善も そういうのは私が言うとすごい嫌な顔をするんです
で 誰か有名な人がそういう話なんかもうちらっと聞いたら
その場合はもうあの人はこういうことを言ってます
先生も知ってますかと
私にも聞きますけどね
面白い 大胆な言葉 話は私はもう次から次にいくらでも言いますけど
で まあそれはどうでもいいんですけど
やっぱりこのポイントね
文明っていうのは怠けの上で成り立っている
だから文明 経済発展 科学発展
あれこれやと発展考える場合は
もう怠けを我々正当化している
怠けがありがたい 怠けが神様なんですよ
今の人々は何に拝んでるかというと
怠けを拝んでるんですよ
まあ例えば では私は神社の神様を拝んでいる
あれ 怠けを拝んでるんですよ
神社の神様にも 100円ぐらい放り投げて
もう 500万円ぐらいのものを期待するでしょうに
明らかに怠けでしょうね
キリスト教の神様に何をお祈りしてるんですかね
みんな気楽にもう幸福になること
敵を倒すこと それにお祈りしてるでしょうね
だから怠けなんですよ
だから結局宗教といっても
みんな宗教でお祈りするんだぞとか
なんとか私はできている人間だと言いながらも
実際やっていることはいかに怠けるかということ
はい それから普通の話に戻ります
もう発展の問題点 で 発展の色々我々考えなくちゃいけない問題点があります
矛盾がつきもの 発展には
それが私にとってとても面白いことなんです
みんな怠けるために必死で苦労しているんです
余裕はない 休みがありません
でしょ？現代人には 日本人休みなんかあるんですかね
で 同時にすっごく言わるんですよ
胸を張って この国はもう経済大国で
あらゆる便利なものはいたく簡単に手に入るんだぞとかね
テレビなんかが日本に現れた
紹介された時は テレビ 1台の値段というのは人の 1年分の給料でしたけど
だから相当金持ちの人以外は買えなかったんで
それも白黒 今は1軒の家で 3台
4台とかあるでしょうね
だからなんて幸せかと
またすごく胸が張るでしょうに
私はあんた方休みでもありますかと
ちょっと一息する時間でもありますかと
全くも休みがない 昔 動物は労働に使う
その何動物っていうんですか？家畜じゃなくて
英語では単語ありますけど
え？ 使役動物  使役 使役使役
使役動物  使うに役に立つ
使うに役立てるのよ  まあ使役動物
だから例えばまあ牛がね
まあ田んぼの仕事をするわ
馬もするわ タイやらね
自分の国でもゾウも結構仕事をするわ
で 砂漠になってくるとラクダも仕事をするし
それで私たちはそういう動物を飼っているでしょうに
あの動物の立場を考えてください
何の立場もないでしょうに
ほんのちょっと餌をもらって
言われる通りに苦労して仕事をしなくちゃいけない
労働組合もありません
ストもできません ボーナスもありません
仕事終わったらどこかでもう捨てて置いておくだけで
本当に苦労するんで 贅沢しているのはこの競馬ですとか馬ぐらいでしょうに
それはかなり金が入るんだから
まあまた馬も高いんだから
もうかなり贅沢に馬小屋に入れておくんですけど
他の馬たちはもうそのまま
もうもう何て言いますか
この放し飼いで 雪が降ろうがもう全然気にしない
競馬だったら寒い時はもう暖房をつけてあげるんです
体にもいろいろ服を着せたりして
その動物以外は何の贅沢もないんですね
この使役動物たちには
我々の立場から見ると
悲しいでしょ 惨めでしょ
あの生き方は それで仕事できなくなっちゃうと殺して食べるんです
走ってる馬でも走れなくなっちゃうと殺すでしょうに
殺して食べるんですよ
かわいそうでしょ すごくなんと惨めでしょ
では自分たちは何なのかね
我々人間は 結局使役動物じゃないんですか
そんな無意味なもう労働組合とかなんとかあるとしたっても
あれ状態は変わりませんよ
朝から晩まで労働者みたいに苦労しなくちゃいかない
で それでちょっとでも仕事を失敗すると
もう全部パー all 終わっちゃうんです
社会から放り出される
それで年取ってくると
全くもう荷物はつかい
役に立たないと 経済発展に何も貢献しないと
老人たちは だからどうやって騙して年金払えないようにするのかっていうことで
今一生懸命研究中です
そんな研究しなくたっても
日本の方々は自分でものを考えないんだからね
楽やと思いますけどね
簡単に騙されますよ だから我々の状態っていうのは
このもう矛盾っていうのは
私はこの矛盾ということを説明したいんですよ
だから食器洗うのは時間かかるんだから
何するかというと 食器洗い機を買うでしょうに
というんですか？ディッシュウォッシャー
食器洗い機は買う でも
食器洗い機を買うためにはスペースが必要だし
お金もかかるし その分はそれかというと
手になるために冷蔵庫から掃除機やら食器洗い機
それからもう大判やあれこれ電子レンジ
まあいろんなものあるでしょうに
まあ体から言えば 髪の毛のてっぺんまで
足の爪先までもう使う道具いっぱいあるんです
これにこれ まあ男たちだからそんなにわかりませんだけど
もう私たちって 例えば鼻毛を切る道具もあるし
爪を切る場合でも 手の爪切る道具と足の爪切る道具
また別々なんです 面倒くさいんだから
同じもので今スネキリで切りますけど
本当はそうじゃないんで
ありますよ 専門的な道具
別に そこで料理に合わせて調理する
スパゲッティを茹でるものとジャガイモを茹でる
また別でしょうに で 普通の炒め物に使うプライパンと天ぷらに使うプライパン
また違うんですからね
匙の種類 包丁の種類 あのイチゴのヘタを取る道具までありますからね
だからそういう道具あるんだから
一般的な皆様はあることも知らないかもしれません
だからただ指でチョキッと
あれ？あれはダサいんですよ
文化的じゃないんです
ちゃんと道具できちんと取った方がかっこいいんです
これ でも信じられ数えられない
どれぐらいあるかと それぐらい道具で楽をしていますかね
結局は道具の命令によって生きているだけ
我々は自分の生き方は道具に合わせなくちゃいけない
自分のタイムスケジュールはもう全部道具に合わせなくちゃいけないんです
バカじゃないんですかと
自分が自由自在だと思ってるんですけど
私は何時に起きるかということは新幹線が決める
そういう生き方になっているんです
だから こちらに来れば
我々はこの建物の条件に合わせなくちゃいけないんです
人間に自由がないんです
他のところでも建物を借りたりするでしょうに
これこちら行ってはいけない
これは開けてはいけない
あれは触ってはいけないとかね
そのお金もくれと言うんです
家を借りる時も同じことで
我々が借りをするときは
結局あればいけない これはいけない
もうくだらない もう法律にもないものを言うんです
結局全部まとめてお前住んではいけないという意味なんです
だって料理してはいけないとかね
人を呼んではいけないとかね
そんなことあるのかと
で 日本の方々にはそれほど厳しくは言わないんですけど
だからもう住んでるところ潰すのは日本の方々なんで
我々は結構大事に使いますけど
文句はどんどん言える
言う まあとにかくまとめて言うと
仏教的に言うと なんか我々は奴隷で
借りる家が家がマスターなんです
だから家の命令に従って生きていなくちゃいけないんです
で 家が現代的になる あればなるほど隙間だらけでいろんなもの道具つけてるんだから
ゴキブリにとっては一番すごく居心地のいいところで
それで空気の流れが悪いんだから
どこでカビが生えるかわからない
カビは黒カビなんかドーンとたくさん発生すればもう目に見えますけど
空気中にあるんだから
それはずっと吸ってるんですよ
だから肺っていうのはカビが発生するためにはすごくいいところなんです
で 肺の中でもカビが発生する
それで健康もなくなっちゃってわからないよ
医者レントゲンで見えませんだからね
ですから この矛盾ということ
すごいお金がある商売をやってる人だったら
もう日本で商談をして
すぐ飛んでパリに飛んで
またアメリカに飛んでとか
現代我々は発展しているんだなと思ってるだけでしょうに
あの刺激動物みたいに動かす動いてるだけ
そこでまあ 我々はこうやってあらゆるものを発展してきたところで
どんどんなめくることはできなくなっちゃったんです
それで頑張ってるかというと
そうじゃないんです また悔しくて
もっと発展させてやるぞという怠けたいっていうことはずっとあるんです
もういい加減 一度も怠けることできなかったんだからやめればいいのに
でもそれはやめません
だからさらに人間が怠けたいにしようと思っちゃうと
とんでもない世界になるんですよ
こういう風に発展していっちゃうと
もうなりますよ 例えば空気も買わなくちゃいけないことになりますからね
今 水を買っているでしょうに
20年前考えられたんですか？今
平気で誰でも水を買う
もうちょっと時間経つと空気も買わなくちゃいけない
発展のおかげで それって便利
そうすると自分のブランドのシャネルとかブランドの空気をセット持っていくと
そうそうなっちゃうんですよ
だから空気はもう売るようになったところで
これブランド品がありますよ
それでまた見栄を張って倍お金を払って
ブランド品の空気セットを買って
そうするとこういう電車ではもうちょっと不便だからね
また電車の中身 また変えなくちゃいけなくなっちゃうんです
大変ですよ 電車でちょっと長い旅をする場合は
そちらで空気を提供しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
そうすると 一人一人に衛生的に別々な道具をつけてつけてあげないと
それでまたその空気は体に合わない人は
自分専用の空気セットを持っていかなくちゃいけないし
もう大変になると思います
だからまあ この誰でも将来をビジョン
イマジネーションする場合は
妄想する場合は結構明るい将来をイマジネーションするでしょうね
なぜかというと この怠けをとことん潰してやるぞと思っているんだから
結局矛盾なんですよ 怠けなくなっちゃうんです
怠けるために必死で苦労するという矛盾が成り立つんです
それを覚えてほしい 我々は怠けるために必死で苦労しているんだ
苦労は嫌なんです だからさらにもう嫌な気持ちになるんです
それであの表面的には楽になっている
あの発展は悪いという人間は一人もいませんよ
私もいません 言いません
発展悪いとは いろんなものを便利なものあるんだから
それは結局表面的なんですね
私もワープやらそういうものを使ってはいますから
それは便利なんですけど
でも裏があるんですよ
それに支配される だから裏面では自己破壊している
昨日夜 これを作って作ろうかなと思っていたんです 11
時半 12時になってくると
自分の時間だから なんか分からないんですけど
コンピューターなかなか動かない
プログラム全部もうハングアップする
信じられないほど遅くなっちゃって
それで終了もできん それで強引に終了しちゃうと
プログラムに問題あるんだと言って
マイクロソフト会社からそこは直してくださいと
突然会社からあれなんとか入ってきて
それでもプログラムのところは同じ
このプログラムですけど
これ直すところで これは ２回セットで直さなくていけなかったんです
で 直してみたら 何かメモリ関連のプログラムがまた引っかかって
それでも動かない それで全部あそこに置いておいて
で 今日朝作ることになった
だから機械に一応自分の時間も全部もうやられているんです
で 裏面では自己破壊している
科学発展で裏に何があるかというと自己破壊なんですよ
例えば今使っているあの化石燃料はやがて終わるでしょうね
でもただでは終わりませんよ
化石燃料は地球環境まで破壊して自分も終わるんですよ
ただでは済みません いっぱい石油を使っているのは
まあいくつかの国々なんですけど
すべての人類はそれをお金払わなくちゃいけない
それに 裏で全部破壊していくんですよ
化石燃料終わるところでありがたいということになりません
もう後戻りできないほどのシステムは破壊する
だからそこは計算して
もう原発からいろんなものを作っているでしょうに
特にもっと怖いプルトニウムでしたっけ？まあ
日本で使っているでしょうし
だから日本の技術っていうのは
表面で口だけだったら世界一なんですよ
実際はもう事故ばっかりでしょうに
ロケットは爆発するわ
1 分間もう 2 3 秒でも 100億
300億とかね 言っちゃうわ
そんな生ぬるい技術で
世界一と言える場合でも
アフリカとかアジアに比べて言うんだからね
もうバカでいいとこなんですよ
日本の技術は世界一と言いたければ
それなりの国と対照しなくちゃいけないでしょうに
で とにかくもう自己満足ということでね
これまた危険でしょうに
だからこのプルトニウムはいろんなものを使って原発なんか作ったりして
ちょっと何かでも滑っちゃうとどうなるかわからない
それで我々はあまりにも忙しくなっているんだから
人間としてもうすべて失っているでしょ
家族制度はありません
互いに愛することはまるっきりわからない
あの政府のコマーシャルあるでしょ
我が子なに愛し方わかりませんという
だから子供を愛しなさいということにも
もう 4000万  5000万使わなくちゃいけないでしょ
そんなところじゃないでしょ
コマーシャルだからね
億単位でしょ ただ単に 1 行
自分の子供を抱きしめてあげてくださいと
その 1 行を言うために億
短期で国の財産はなくなるんです
それと素晴らしいですね
発展のおかげで わかりますか？いかに矛盾で変かということ
自己破壊でしょうね 子供を愛せない母親っていうのは人生楽しいと思いますか？ものすごい精神的にいかれちゃう
どうすればいいかと 捨てたいんだけど
捨てちゃうと法律で捕まれるし
たまったまま殺したり捨てたりはそれもしますけど
だいたいはないんだからね
でも育ち方はわからないし
それで人間は一人で生活できるはずもないんですよ
もともとの精神的な貧弱で貧弱者でしょうね
その上 独立で一人で生活すると
だからすっぺておかしくなってしまうんです
そういうはすべて自己破壊につながるんです
今体力もないでしょうし
もうちょっと天気が変わると体が壊れるでしょうし
道具なしには動けない
各仕事によって手袋は買わな買えなくちゃいけない
各仕事によって靴を変えなくちゃいけない
服を変えなくちゃいけない
作業服も仕事に合わせていろいろあるんだから
体が弱いっていうことなんです
そのように我々は精神的にも自己破壊をしています
家族制度を壊れたこと
他の人々と自然に仲良く喋ることはできない
どこでも気楽にいられない
人間見ると怖くなる 人間いるとあ
嫌だとかね 逃げたりもする
もうもうどこかでももう動物になってるんですよ
人間見ると嫌がる 逃げるっていうことは
もう野生動物やってることですけど
堂々と人間やってますよ
それが いいところは認めないだけ
私が坊主のくせに悪口言ってるんだっていうことで終わっちゃうんです
まぁやっとのすくい それだけなんで
事実だけは認めませんと
という人間の生き方 本当のことは言うなよと
とことん嘘を言ってくださいと
我々は大変楽しいんだということだけは
もうなんとか自己ごまかしできますが
でも本当はもう壊れていくんですよ
実際はどんどん自己破壊しているんです
この発展の特色 それなんです
発展志向で肉体の楽しか考えられない
それで発展 発展って言っても
我々は考えているのは肉体の楽なんですよ
他は何も考えていない
精神の発展と怠けが両立しないからです
なぜ精神的な発展 誰も言わないんでしょうかね
誰一人も言わない 売れない
精神的なとこを言うと追い出される
ということは 我々は基本的に怠けたい
怠けたい 怠けたいということだから
精神的な発展は怠けたいということが成り立たない
両立しない だから どんな哲学者が
どんな科学者が どんな優秀な人が
どんな優秀な国々が世界を発展しようと思って何やっても
単なる肉体の楽以外何も考えていない
だからこういう風な自己破壊ということになります
それは発展の問題点なんですね
では 次に行きます それから怠けについていくらか考えてみましょう
で 我々は怠けっていうのは肉体のことだと思ってますが
だからまあ運動する人は怠けてない人でしょう
朝早く行って散歩に行くならば
あの方はすごく頑張っているんだと
だから我々知っている怠けっていうのは体の怠けなんです
怠けているのは体ではなく心なのです
これをそのまま覚えるしかないんですよ
説明したって意味がないんです
一般的に我々は怠けというのは体のこと
ちょっと朝寝坊したら
なんで怠けているんでしょうかとかね
朝寝坊しないで 朝早く起きてラジオ体操でもやっているんだったら
しっかりしている人でしょ
ちゃんと朝ごはん作って
ちゃんと家洗濯をして
掃除機をかけて それからピシピシと買い物に行って
昼ご飯を用意して それからまた次のなんとかやって
それで夜10時半まで12時まであれこれとやってるのはもう頑張ってるんです
今日は料理はなんか作りたくない
朝ごはんだけで十分だよと思っちゃうと
あの人は本当に危ないんだと
怠けてるんだと思う 体のことは怠けじゃないんです
怠けっていうのは心のことなんです
心の怠けが体で現れる
ただそれだけ 心が機能しない
怠けたいと思っちゃうと
体で現れる 体も怠けるということで
行動しないということにする
だから怠けっていうのは心のことなんです
体が怠けると反発的に心も怠ける
ここから悪循環なんですよ
今日はもうもう 11時まで寝るぞと
朝ごはんも食べないぞという思って
もう午前中寝ていると
もうまず心が怠けてるんですね
心が怠けてるんだから
どうせ起きません それで 11時になってきたら
もう逆にまた心が怠けていくんですね
逆に体の反応で あ もっとよくわかる
例えば 長い時間ずっと座りっぱなしで
外へ出ない人がなかなか外へ出る気がなくなっちゃうんですよ
最初は仕事とかいろんなことかもしれませんだけど
どんどんそれで居心地がよくなって
外へは出られなくなっちゃうんです
まあいいやと 外へ出たっても
すぐ出て早く帰ってくるんです
それで午後散歩なんかしようと思っても
もうできない もう強引に行ってもすぐ疲れる
散歩に行っても どこか腰をかけるところないのかと
そればっかしで だからずっと人生っていうのは
そういうと矛盾ばっかしで
もうもうどこかで行こうかなと思ったら
もう朝食べるもの 昼食べるもの
夜食べるもの 飲み物 あれこれとか
トラック 1台ぐらい持っていかなくちゃいけないんですよ
それでどこか行って あれは全部広げて
また食べて もう時間終わったんだから
また畳んでもう帰るんですね
遊べないんですよ 皆様
映画なんかでもよく見るでしょうに
この何て言いますか このもうハイキングじゃなくて
いろんな外へ出て みんなもう遊ぶ
何のこともない海のところに行って
テーブルを引いて それでテーブルクロスを入れて
またもう花のあれ 何て言いますか
花瓶も入れて それで料理作って食う
外で作る料理だから便利でもないし
だったら家で作って来ればいいのに
また全部畳んでまた戻る
車を運転して渋滞もなのに
だからどこで理性的かとわからない
自然破壊するわ 特別な運動もしてないわ
だから怠けちゃうと体が怠けに
もう心が怠けると体が怠ける
体が怠けると体はそれが居心地がいいんです
動けなくなっちゃうんです
そうすると体から心にまた反応がいくんですよ
それが一番嫌なんです
2番目の怠けは 不幸 苦しみ云々として認識するんです
なんてわけ 不幸なのかとかね
あれもやりたいんだけどできないんだとかね
すっごく苦しいんですよ
この2番目の怠けが 一番目は心が怠ける
だから体もその影響を受けて動かないようにする
体が動かないと この動かない体から心へ新しい2番目の怠けの信号が入るんです
これですよ 不幸っていうのは
悩みも苦しみもあれこれと
テレビで見たんですけど
なんかもうちょっとしたトラブル起こっちゃって
誰かがもう食べ始めて
どんどん体がもう増えちゃって
もう立てなくなったって
ベッドに寝たまんまで
もう 300 キロぐらいとかね
もう寝返りもできん 誰に他の人にそれすることもできない
それでその人はもう強引に治療させなくちゃいけないということで
もう外へ出せないんです
それでまあ窓を破って
上から機械で運んだんです
体っていうのは その人がそれでもなんで毎日あれほど食べるかというと
それ ベッドにずっといて
あれは居心地がいいんですよ
最初はちょっとした心の怠けなんです
これで体が怠けてしまって
体から心に影響を与えると
人格まで何から何まで潰れてしまうんです
だからこの2番目の怠けも覚えておいてください
あの体っていうのはもうどうってことないんですよ
肉体は だから決して怠けっていうのは肉体的なことではございません
それはもう精神的なことなんです
はい それから怠けの治療方法になりますので
一旦休憩いたします といったん怠けにいたします
[笑い]